we have a special car coming up here the
serenity I think we're gonna have some
of your helpers undress it if I can use
them sure pleasure on sir let some bless
the KY address the car I mean we you
know all right we're gonna slice up here
now this is a bespoke vehicle right yeah
this is a car for a customer who really
challenged us to go an extra mile this
is for the first time that we brought
fabric back into a car this hand woven
silk inside let me open the car for you
guys can I come in no this is
unfortunately why can I go you afraid
I'm gonna blunder can I touch the
customer asked me really that we are not
touching not entering it for very good
reasons so in that it is so delicate uh
this is silk and it's completely
delicate this is hand-woven and also
painted on top of that it took us nearly
a year to build this extraordinary car
here nearly a year what was the price
tag on it substantial as you can image
that less or more than two million euros
Oh substantial as I said so we're gonna
take that as higher than two million
years
tell us tell us about the bespoke market
the bespoke market in general is very
important for us it is at the end of the
day when you decide for Rose Royce you
want to specify that car to your own
imagination and that is why we have
installed that P spoke program which is
in the meantime highly successful 90
percent of all of our cars are P spoked
even up to those levels here but of
course this car is for us also or was a
new challenge particular when you look
on the headliner of this car here you
see that everything is completely hand
volved into the headline here and that
is something we haven't done before
in the hole I fell well I could make a
really indiscreet joke about people who
see the ceilings of cars but we won't
talk about that not at all tell us you
you had a great year yeah five years of
growth right tell us what you're
expecting in 2015
I mean I'm quietly confident that we
should see again a very good year here
for us Royce in 2015 I mean we had as
you said five years consecutive growth
in a row which is a fantastic story
broke for the first time over 4,000
units last year and I'm quietly
confident that we should sell at least
one car more this year
so more than four thousand six hundred
sixty three run yeah talk to me about
Russia you last year you saw a lot of
people parking their assets in Rolls
Royce is that trend going to continue I
mean Russia is in the moment extremely
hard to predict this you know of course
all what happened here over the last
couple of days that is of course also
affecting in general the mood of the
whole population and of course also the
mood of potential buyers of our cars so
for that reason I'm not sure if we see
Russia again being such a strong market
as it had been last year so for that but
on the other side the United States is
an excellent market for us Middle East
is in good shape and that comes all back
to my old saying you should never put
all your eggs in one basket make sure
that you are globally nicely balanced
when you look at the Middle East you're
not being affected by the lower price of
oil I mean the oil price now is
stabilizing anyhow and it's not only
about oil in that area it is also very
much of course about the stock market
the stock market is also stabilizing now
and for that reason I'm not too much
worried about the Middle East and also
what we have seen here in the beginning
of the years it's ok it really develops
nicely we had a record year also last
year Middle East the Middle East is in
the meantime our second biggest market
after the United States China has there
been a slowdown because of the
anti-corruption campaign yes we have
seen that last year we sold
substantially less cars in comparison to
2013 very much due to that
anti-corruption campaign by the
government that also underlines that we
are not immune against any government
mental actions and I think we're going
to see the same happening this year so
it will take some time until this effect
really goes and we see the market coming
back to normal
you unveil this car for us here unveil
your plans for an SUV force we unveiled
that already we confirmed it as you know
two weeks ago and we are very much
looking forward to that car we take our
time to really develop it properly and
to make sure that it is a proper release
by the end of the day we are finalizing
now the design phase of the kind and we
start all the engineering takes a couple
of years after the car comes into the
market and have you heard from customers
a day there's demand part I already have
some orders in our order bank for that
car when we announced it immediately I
got a couple of orders in from customers
all over the world and of course also
our dealers are highly excited by it and
many customers even asked us to enter
into that segment for very good reasons
not only a CEO but a salesman a car
salesman always working the brand yeah I
mean of course you always on duty here
if you work for that pristine brand
Rose rose motorcars and for that reason
being close with customers listening to
customers I would even say we are
probably one of the most customer driven
automotive brands in the world having
let's say a very exclusive family of
customers which is odd because very few
of your customers actually drive your
cars they have someone drive them for
them no that's not right what's the
percentage yeah I know the percentage
now for race for instance hundred
percent of all our customers drive the
car themselves
it's a fastback coupe a you don't want
to be driven in the fastback coupe a
also ghost 50% is self drivers 50% of
chauffeured phantom limousine this type
of car is very much a chauffeured car
that's right now is are there stock
seats in the front as well no only in
the back because in the past fabrics and
silk we're the place to sit on and
was meant for the chauffeur so what are
some of the more interesting bespoke
requests you have what happens if I'm a
larger gentleman can I get a guy get a
larger seat in there what would you
could all have that even if you're a
smaller guy or whatever everything is
possible we even it just seats up to
your own configuration that is possible
there okay well with that configuration
you and I can talk prices offline I know
you didn't give me a number but I'm
gonna say north of 2 million euros and
unless you object that's how much you
guys can have this car for north of 2
million euros your final chance to
object sir it's substantial amount of
money as I said